now eu finance ministers have been
meeting today in paris to discuss
further sanctions against russia germany
is under increasing pressure to drop its
opposition to cutting off russia's
access to the swift money transfer
system
now robin wagner is a member of the
german parliament for the green party
and sits on the parliament's committees
on foreign and european affairs
let's wait for him to be thank you
welcome to dw um why is germany so
opposed to cutting russia off from the
global financial system
i think it's not only talking about the
word swift and
the feelings that you have with talking
about swift
but we definitely need to have strong
sanctions against russia as we are
facing an aggression against
international peace order and against us
as a whole so we need to have a package
of sanctions that really work and that
really
push hard against russia's capabilities
to finance their war and we need to have
a good calculation between what we do
and what would be the retaliation that
comes from russia and i think we need to
take all of this into account and it's
not only talking about the word swift
but to have a good package that directly
addresses those responsible and directly
addresses uh everything that is
necessary to cut off financing
you say that we need to have a set of
sanctions that will allow us to push
hard against russia's ability to finance
its wars
wouldn't cutting it off from swift
achieve that
that could be one part of such a package
but we also have other measures that
we're taking right now that also um
really
go strong go strong steps to that goal
without having the negative side effects
of cutting off
from swift so what are the negative side
effects that you fear what is the
russian retaliation that you fear
well we would definitely cut off
everything that could happen between
russia and the rest of the world and um
that would be a strong problem also for
civil society within russia we would cut
them off directly from
uh from from total financial systems um
and we have other measures that have
strong effects as well
is to give people watching uh dw now
this is your opportunity to tell them
this is why it is bad to cut russia off
from swift if if we cut russia off from
swift these will be the negative
consequences the stage is yours
no it's not only talking about swift
please please please please address that
point please you can address the others
that's fine but this is the big one on
the table so
swift is the one that germany opposes
explain to the audience why it would be
a bad thing to cut russia off from its
ability to finance its wars by by
cutting it off from swift explain to us
what the negative consequences would be
no we would not cut off russia with this
one measure from financing their wars
it's a package of measures that we need
at the moment and we need a strong
unified european position on all these
measures and it's it's
not a good idea to focus solely on on
swift we have other measures in this
package that will work on the way to
cutting off russia from financing their
war and we totally focus in the debate
on swift which is not a very good idea
it's not only this one aspect this one
aspect is what makes us all feel good
that we have done everything we could
but there are other measures in the
package that are quite strong for
example today there were uh even
sanctions against uh putin and lavrov
which was not something that has has
been done in
ways of sanctionings before
you've talked about this you've talked
about a strong european response this is
the third set of sanctions that europe
has imposed on russia there was a set
after it brought down
mh111 there was a set that you agreed
before this uh war happened and this is
the third set
where is the evidence that any of this
has had the slightest impression
on russia
i think we're not talking about the last
sets of sanctions we're talking about
this set of sanctions and we
we have a strong set of sanctions at the
moment
germany was attracted even more okay if
necessary but at the moment we have a
strong set of sanctions on the table
one of the criticisms that that germany
has faced
is that it puts its own commercial
interests with russia ahead of wider
considerations
right
and and it has taken your the german
chancellor so long to even use the words
nordstrom ii
i'm going to presume that you that you
are going to say that that criticism of
germany is
unfair as a green party in germany we
have a long history of strong strongly
opposing north stream 2 in this package
we have had that quite a lot of times
before
and it's
north stream 2 is a geopolitically wrong
project and it's very good that it's off
the table and the foreign minister
analina berbock made it very clear that
germany is willing to pay its price for
a strong set of sanctions and for really
acting against this aggression against
international law and peace in in europe
thank you so much for joining us robin
wagner member of the german parliament
for the greens
thank you
well the latest sanctions against russia
include in terms of the financial sector
the u.s is putting restrictions against
all major russian banks meanwhile the eu
is also cutting the ability of the
russian state to access the bloc's
capital markets there are asset freezers
and travel bans for a number of
individuals including politicians and
oligarchs with close ties to putin there
are further sanctions against the
russian energy sector after putting the
nord stream 2 pipeline on hold the eu is
threatening to curb exports and imports
for gas giant gazprom other sanctions
target the technology sector as well the
eu will stop supplying high-tech
components and software to russia and
the u.s says it will severely restrict
russia's access to semiconductors
computers and telecoms equipment still
on the table though is disconnecting
russia from the international payment
system swift but that would come with
severe problems for western countries
too and so far hasn't been agreed upon
well we can now speak to veronica grimm
from the german council of economic
experts thanks a lot for joining us
let's talk a bit more about the latest
eu sanctions what impact are they
actually going to have on russia
so meanwhile the eu summit agreed on a
package that had been prepared for weeks
so access of major russian banks to your
european capital markets will be blocked
um assets of certain russians in europe
will be frozen um goods for the energy
industry may no longer be delivered to
russia and some other sanctions so the
fact that these sanctions were passed
without much controversy can be seen as
a sign of particularly good preparation
or also inadequate preparation because
after all
in a view of the massive invasion
maybe tougher sanctions would also have
been appropriate and
one has not decided to cut out russia
from the swift payment system so this
would be a quite tougher um
section that has not been chosen up to
now yeah they have decided that they're
not going to exclude russia from this
sim to this system that would you know
make it very difficult for russia to
trade with other countries why have they
stopped short of that at this stage
um
so it has been said um that um there
have to be uh sanctions and
that would remain in case more severe
sanctions would be appropriate
however this situation might have been
occurred already today so the swift
sanctions
would have the practical effect that
cross-border payments would no longer be
possible and would also restrict
payments within russia so this would be
a quite a severe sanction actually and
it had been applied before to other
countries in the past for example iran
north korea or afghanistan
for example in iran after the 2012
exclusion
half of the oil exports and assert of
international trade of iran had
collapsed so it had a very big impact on
iran but it is being saved up like you
said germany is one of the countries
that says that it wants to
keep this sort of uh in the armory for
use later on but what sort of a
situation would it take for this
actually to happen
um
this is very hard to answer for me so
i think
the invasion has been massive up to now
and um it seems that the situation has
also not been expected
in the way it happened before so i would
think that an exclusion of swift would
be appropriate as a sanction but it has
not been decided maybe because it had
not been prepared um sufficiently up to
now
right but there are eu member states
that are pushing for it poland for
example
latvia countries that feel a lot more
under threat from russia i want to talk
about
actually the impact of what's happening
in ukraine for ordinary europeans it's a
continent that's already struggling with
inflation and an energy crunch those
things that are going to get worse
because of what's happening in ukraine
um yeah the gas prices are currently at
a very high level and the situation is
not expected to ease in the short term
especially if
the gas supply
from russia is decreasing now due to the
crisis it is not clear whether this
would happen and at what time
this this could happen
however wholesale prices will gradually
passed on to consumers so gas prices are
very high the path on two consumers
is slow because many of them have
longer-term contracts but further price
increases um are to be expected for
further process products for example um
the price increases will spread to
fertilizer and then also to food so the
inflation is likely to remain high this
year and we should see at least a four
before the decimal point for 2022
and this makes of course second round
effects the
wage price barrel
more likely and puts a lot of pressure
at the ecb in a situation that is very
complicated in europe at the moment
okay veronica grimm from the german
council of economic experts thank you so
much for bringing us your insights
thank you
and i'm now joined in the studio by
cassandra sunt from dw business
cassandra we've just been hearing about
the sanctions that are coming russia's
way and could be coming russia's way has
moscow been preparing for a moment like
this yes they have part of the problem
here is that this was first dangled as
an option this idea that russia could be
kicked out of the swift banking system
back in 2014 when russia annexed crimea
so at the time russia responded in a
typically bombastic fashion saying that
kicking it out of the swift system would
be the equivalent of a declaration of
war so the time western allies put it on
the back burner that was in 2014 over
seven years ago russia has had time to
build up what many are calling a
fortress economy they've de-dollarized
massively
20 years ago 80 percent of their
liabilities were in dollars now it's
less than 50 percent they've built up
gold reserves and 643 billion dollars in
currency reserved reserves and they have
one of the lowest debt to gdp ratios in
the entire world so these are all
results uh of a careful plan that putin
has been president putin has been
putting in place since the annex
of
crimea in 2014. but nevertheless this
would have a big impact on how russia
could um deal with the rest of the world
if it were to be kicked out of swift so
and what will russia do if it is
yeah uh we only have one example really
of the u.s successfully getting a
country kicked out of swift that would
be iran so there's not a lot of
historical data to go off of and we are
reading the tea leaves but there are
some fears being floated around that if
russia is kicked out it would undermine
the swift system as a whole and
encourage the development of
alternatives russia does have its own
system spfs but currently it's really
only used by russian banks china
launched its own system in 2015 but
that's really still under development
um it's called the cross-border
international payment system and it's
only used by about 80 foreign banks but
in principle there's no reason it can't
be used as a substitute for swift and
believe it or not there are still some
pre-swift tools that russia could use
russian financial institutions could use
like the telephone and telex and
nowadays you could use email as a secure
business bank to bank a secure messaging
system
these are all tools at russia's disposal
so while removing russia from the swift
system would be cutting it off from a
key highway of global finance there are
other back roads that it could use that
even if they are a little slower and
bumpier and of course the west would
have less control over whatever
alternative russia sought out okay
sanderson thanks for bringing us up
today
you